what you see depicted here is known as a
pedigree and a pedigree is a way of
analyzing the inheritance patterns of a
trait within a family and it can be
useful to understand more about that
trait maybe to make some insights about
the genetics of that trait and it's a
way to think about well what's happened
in the past in a family and then maybe
we can help get some probabilities or
get some understanding of what might
happen in the future but let's just
break it down so that we understand all
of the different parts of a pedigree so
a big picture a circle represents a
female in the family and a square
represents a male in the family if
either the circle or the square is
colored in like we see right over here
or we see right over here that means
that that person exhibits the trait and
the trait that this particular pedigree
is for is the trait of freckles and
whether or not we're colored in that is
a phenotype that is an observed trait
you just look at the person you say do
they have freckles or not this male
right over here does not have freckles
this female right over here does have
freckles this male right over here does
have freckles but once again this
phenotype that's the observed
characteristic we don't know exactly the
genotype just from this although we
might be able to infer some ideas about
the genotype by seeing how the phenotype
pattern spread from generation to
generation but just going back to
understanding the pedigree itself when
you have a horizontal line connecting a
male and a female it's called a marriage
line and it means that they are coupling
up and they are reproducing they don't
necessarily I guess have to be married
it's more that they reproduce so this
male and this female have reproduced and
then this vertical line that goes from
that horizontal line that's known as the
line of descent so it's going from that
first generation to the second
generation and so all of the people
connected to that vertical line at the
bottom of the vertical line these are
their children all of the people who are
directly connected to this and this is
known as a sibling line so this person
this person and
that person they are all brothers and
sisters you can see that generation 1
they had two daughters one of whom
exhibited freckles and one son who had
freckles now these other people in
generation 2 these aren't children of
the first generation these are people
you could say who are brought into the
family they either married into the
family or you could just say they
reproduced with the children but that's
what's happening with generation 2 and
so you can see you have another what's
known as a marriage line but I guess it
could be a coupling line a line of
descent and then they have two daughters
in this case so it turns out that
freckles is an autosomal dominant trait
and I will explain what that means in a
second autosomal dominant dominant trait
autosomal means that it is a trait
associated with one of the non-sex
chromosomes we have 23 pairs of
chromosomes as humans one of those pairs
determines our sex the other ones don't
determine our sex so this means that
freckles is associated with one of the
22 pairs of chromosomes that do not
determine your sex and dominant means
that in general you get two versions of
a gene one from your mom and one from
your father and each of those versions
of the gene for say whether or not you
have freckles is known as an allele and
if a trait is autosomal dominant that
means that if you have even just one
allele for that trait that you are going
to exhibit the trait and so for example
if the alleles for our freckles if
capital F is you have freckles its
dominant so we write it in capital and
lowercase F means that you don't have
freckles if someone has a genotype of
capital F capital F or capital F
lowercase F or I guess we could say
lowercase F capital F if we wanted to
think about order which one you're
getting from which parent well then in
all of these situations they would
exhibit the phenotype of freckles and we
talked about genotype and phenotype in
other videos and of course the only
genotype in which they would not exhibit
freckles would be having both of the
recessive traits
so with this out of the way what can we
infer about the genotype of this
individual right over here and this
individual will sometimes be referred to
as individual one two there in
generation one and they are individual
two in generation one well we know that
they exhibit freckles so we know for
sure that since the phenotype is
freckles they are in one of these
scenarios and these two these two are
frankly equivalent so this person we
know that they're either capital F
capital F so that would be homozygous
dominant or they're capital F lowercase
F which are they they are heterozygous
well let's first think about the
situation if they were homozygous
dominant if they're are homozygous
dominant that means to every one of her
children she would give one of these
alleles and either of those are dominant
and so that would mean if this were the
case that all of her children would get
at least one dominant allele well if
they all get at least one dominant
allele then all of her children would
have freckles but we're seeing a
situation where all of her four children
do not have freckles two of her three
children had freckles so this cannot be
the case so this individual right over
here must be heterozygous for freckles
so they must be capital F lowercase F
and what do we know about this
individual right over here the person
that she coupled up with well they don't
exhibit the phenotype for freckles so
they must be lower case F lower case F
and then from that you might be able to
intuit a lot more about that and we'll
do that in future it worked examples